now notice very carefully what the
interviewer does when he's talking about
that the interview things hold in a
second I need to introduce him to Jesus
if I was interviewed you know I'll say
probably local you believe in Allah
that's that's a lot
[Music]
flighty so high-level feed them
this journey this road that I travel on
it all seems crazy over the years I
picked up thousands of Tagalongs
inspired by my story from a tree for now
what my clothes had holes in them
I'm afro is picky to the night east
maschino and Versace it's no Lacey's
inner Archie's new millennium
assalammualaikum one hunter a better
care to brothers and sisters and dear
friends Muslim or non-muslim welcome to
this video now what we're gonna do is
we're gonna be discussing a very
important video that came about on the
YouTube scene from Logan Paul he makes
free statements which I believe makes
would make every single one of us
specifically our non-muslim friends to
understand who God really is let's watch
this video and pay very close attention
to three things he says tell you like
religion in general and faith sometimes
I the reason cuz I'm not like I said I'm
not overly religious I do believe in a
creator I don't know what his role is in
our day to day lives
III I think there's some sort of
unimaginable thing that made us in this
universe and everything around us but
like I said I don't know if he's as
active as faith would tell you that you
heard free statements lobe important
eight that I believe are statements a
Muslim makes Jesus made Moses made
Abraham made even this go who came to
the Prophet Muhammad peace be upon him
and the process I asked asked him where
is good she did this just pointed up
affirming her belief that statement let
alone lo comport come in and seeing that
there is a creator
he's unimaginable and he created us
brothers and sisters that's what we
believe the Creator Allah subhana WA
Ta'ala says in the Quran in Nephi Hulk
is Sumati well are they worth a life in
lay anyone her Eli Attilio lien Al Bab
now this very statement reminds me of
Logan for why because Allah saying
indeed in the creation of the heavens
and the earth and in the alternation of
the night and day there are signs for
those who believe and local polish
somebody has been around the world and
he's lived the life to the max and he's
affirming God's creation that God
is a creator why because his innate
disposition is affirming that his
affirming he never said I'm confused or
if could exist
oh I'm confused if he's unimaginable or
not or if he's a man or not oh I'm
confused if he created us he was
certainly a Akeem in those free
statements so that's the reason why his
definition with those three things we
can say here that's Allah yes we can
derive more into about his attributes
that's a separate topic now what we're
going to do brother and sisters is that
since we know he said there's a creator
we want to affirm two more things is God
unimaginable and it has God created us
now the next following clip we're gonna
watch for my sister is with the
interviewer the Christian interviewer
who's trying to now come and introduce
Jesus into the picture before that what
was no comport talking about Allah in a
nutshell he was talking about Allah unto
a Christian that has to come and say yo
yo let me tell you B about Jesus let's
watch this clip unless you what's going
on here and here's the catch we're the
only faith system that says it's not
about being good because we cannot be
good enough so Jesus kind of did away
with all that because that's what
religion was religion was working your
way up to God every other faith pray
this long pray this hard do this many
good deeds and then Jesus flipped it and
said I did all that for you now all you
have to do is come to me that's what
blew people's minds that that's why they
were like killed this dude right away
kill him because if he's right
everything we stand for is wrong you
heard very clearly Justin Barrett
carried out an experiment in Austin
University where they spent one point
nine million pounds 57 researchers
around the world conducted over 40
different studies in 20 different
countries with people from all
backgrounds and they found that people
are born with the innate disposition
just like Logan Paul just like grow
comport the innate disposition in the
belief in a higher being now notice very
carefully what the interviewer does when
he's talking about that the interview
things hold in a second I need to
introduce him to Jesus if I was
interviewed you know I'll say probably
local you believe in Allah that's Allah
but what did the Christian is if you do
he said what oh jesus came you know
people for that you work your way up and
that is exactly why people make false
idols such as believe in God is a man
etcetera
now no compost has something very
interesting that absolutely nullifies
all other beliefs including Christianity
What did he say
God is unimaginable unimaginable what do
we say brother and sisters in a quran
chapter 111 Paul who Allahu Ahad Allah
who summit lemnear lead well amulet well
a miracle before when I had say he is
one self-sufficient he does not beget
nor is He begotten listen carefully and
there is nothing like unto him
unimaginable there is nothing like unto
him unimaginable so hold on a second now
Jesus is out of the picture Jesus out of
the picture totally out of the picture
any kind of man-made created things are
out of the picture you can say bye-bye
to that so the Christian man coming and
trying to interject and introduce him to
Jesus
poor Logan Paul was already on the
fitrah now what does he see in expose
I'm gonna finish on this part and I want
you guys woman sisters to send this
video to him we want to get put on to
him and get in contact with us I don't
want any publicity at all privately he
can message me I'll give him my email
gets in contact I do not want any kind
of it doesn t talk about me we just want
to get the right materials for him
because he is damned on the right track
look at his last statement and he
created us okay I'm gonna ask a simple
question
Logan something that creates us can they
become us logically think about it if I
created a chair do I need to become a
chair and if I do become a chair does it
show my strength because some people say
if he's God he can create and does
whatever he likes well hold on hold on a
second so does that show my weakness so
if I go to someone and say listen you're
a boxer Habeeb if you're strong let me
spark you out let me knock you out show
me how strong you are if you let me
knock him out does he show his power or
does it show his weakness so he said he
created us if God has created us he does
not need to become us he does not need
to come down and be a human being
and he can imagine God Almighty the one
that you said he's created unimaginable
he created us eating and going to toilet
like us is that the picture of God you
have of course you don't no you don't
Logan that's why you're Christian Fred
had to interject and
introduce the Jesus to you and just to
finish off guys what did the Christian
guys say just just pick on this he goes
Jesus came and changed the whole
dynamics before people thought that you
worship and you come closer to God Jesus
came and said oh you don't need to do
that anymore this is the very
fundamental thing why people turn to
idol worship you know why because people
come and say what we're not good enough
we're sinners we can how can we come to
the presence of God what can we do what
is Christianity say blood sacrifice is
required an innocent man has to die or
in other words if you have a different
belief system which is that God had to
come in can you imagine God dying yeah
God was on the cross and his creation
was killing him God had to die this is
what's being told what does Islam say no
blood sacrifice nobody needs to die no
innocent person listed I know blasphemy
of God coming to earth and killing
himself suicide 1 is murder one is
suicide one is killing his son
one is committing suicide none of that
our last of hano tell us is something
very simple i'ma finish on this note if
the sins of Adam mankind was to reach
the heavens and the earth I will forgive
every single one as long as you do not
worship any other God no camp or I
believe you are so on the right track to
believe you you literally believe in God
that's a concept that's our concept of
God he is one there is nothing like him
he's the source of power he's created
the heavens in the earth get in contact
with us we are happy to help you behind
the scenes we do not want nothing from
you
Logan we do not want to admit you don't
need to mention my name nothing get in
contact we'll get you guys get you the
right materials in America and we would
like to help you on this journey
brothers and sisters thank you for
watching and I want to thank Bob Bashara
smart agenda subscribe to his channel
may Allah bless him he opens his doors
to us feeds us looks after us records
these videos and put smile on our faces
may Allah bless him and his family that
they smile all the way to journey
inshallah and we can have a party in his
house in Germany assalamu alaikum enter
a better care to brothers and sisters
and their friends hope you guys are well
inshallah I welcome to this video now a
recent video has been going around about
poor Logan now a lot of people with your
video
[Laughter]
okay okay okay we believers okay I miss
Janice wah wah
okay assalamualaikum I haven't really
better care to brothers and sisters and
dear friends welcome to this video and
[Laughter]
okay